usually Palin Unger writes about other
people and their stories now she's
making headlines herself after being
sentenced to jail for defamation and
insult and slandering a public official
says I expected this verdict because
here in Turkey as a journalist I always
have one foot in jail I'm not the only
one many reporters are in the same
position but we try not to let it get us
down and we'll just carry on doing our
job
she was the up might show shows Palin
has been reporting for dwz Turkish
service since last year before that she
was part of the international network of
investigative journalists who analyzed
and published the so called paradise
papers leaks confidential documents
revealing the offshore accounts of
politicians businesspeople and
multinational companies who are avoiding
taxes and sometimes evading them during
her research Palin found an alleged
connection to the family of the former
Turkish Prime Minister yielded him and
wrote articles for it for the Turkish
daily newspaper Jim Harriet Hilde rim
sued her a cinebulle bagosa yankin de
this is an attempt to intimidate not me
personally or my articles but the whole
journalism profession the messages if
you report freely you will be punished
that's the situation for journalists
here in Turkey Nikita she may have been
sentenced but Palin is not in prison yet
she wants to appeal and while her case
continues she hopes she will be able to
focus on writing stories again instead
of being the center of attention herself